>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Robert Newlen: On behalf acting
Librarian of Congress, David S. Mao,
I'm pleased to be here to
introduce Jo Ann Jenkins.
I'm Robert Newlen, Chief of Staff
for the Library of Congress and it's
so wonderful to see so many people
here today in this beautiful room.
Jo Ann Jenkins is no stranger
to the Library of Congress
and we're a better
place because of her.
As the libraries Chief of
Staff, Jo Ann was a disruptor
and I don't mean making a lot
of noise in the reading rooms.
But in her fifteen years here,
she changed the way the nation
interacts with its library.
Among her many special
contributions,
she lead the many bi-centennial
celebrations of the Library.
She led and grew the
National Book Festival,
the nation's premier celebration
of literacy and reading.
She re-energized the
junior fellows program,
which gives talented college
students internships at the library.
She spearheaded the young reader's
center to provide a special place
at the library for young
children and their families.
She designed an award winning,
state of the art new experience
for visitors to the Library.
She launched an innovative upward
mobility and health related programs
for staff and she intergraded
the Libraries unique facility
in Culpepper Virginia housing
the nation's film, television,
radio and sound recording heritage
into the Culpepper community.
Jo Ann left the Library in two
thousand and ten to become President
of the AARP Foundation,
AARP's charitable arm.
As President of the
Foundation, Jo Ann transformed
that organizations far
reaching development
and social impact initiatives
including the drive to end hunger,
a national effort to help
millions of older Americans
who struggle with hunger every day.
Under her leadership,
the foundations overall
donor base increased
by ninety percent in two years.
She was appointed Chief Operating
Officer in two thousand thirteen
and made executive officer
of the thirty eight million
member organization in September
of two thousand and fourteen.
We are very proud to count AARP
among our esteemed private sector
partners who are instrumental in
advancing the libraries mission.
With her track record for making
a difference, this is no surprise
to me that she finally
decided to write
down her thoughts on disruption.
I am particularly interested in how
she disrupted the aging paradigm
because it directly affects me.
In fact whether you are of age,
guilty, or are dealing with parents
or friends that are, I suspect
that everyone here today will
learn something they can apply
to improve their quality of life.
I do have just one bone
to pick with you Jo Ann,
how is it since you have become the
spokesperson for changing the air
of aging paradigm, how
is it you never age?
You know many years later here I am
with this white hair,
what can I say.
It's a great pleasure to welcome
Jo Ann back to the Library
to tell us how she launching a
national movement to disrupt aging.
[ Applause ]
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: Well thank you
Robert and thank you all for coming
out to talk about disrupting
aging today.
As we were waiting over
at the ceremonial office,
one of my favorite
place, I told my colleague
from AARP don't touch
anything because if you come
into this room you have
to give a million dollars.
So I wanted to make sure when
they said do you want water,
we said no we don't want anything.
But thank you all today and thank
you Robert for sort of going
through that list of projects
that really have so much meaning
in my life and as I was saying I
had the good fortune last week to be
in New York for the Women
of the World conference
and Laura Bush was there with
us and we were reminiscing
about the National Book Festival
with John and Sue and so many all
of you who worked on the National
Book Festival and I recall saying
to her, do you remember
our first meeting
and I asked you what would
success look like and she said
if we could get five thousand
people that would be great
and we all have a different
answer as to how many showed up on
that first book festival.
It sort of goes anywhere
from fifteen thousand people
to thirty thousand, but we're
certainly above the five thousand
that she start, so,
good to be back here.
I want to start today by
having a conversation with you
about disrupt aging,
which is our new book
that we put out two weeks ago.
And why it's so important
this whole idea
of age disruption and
what it is we do.
So the first really
idea around this is
that the way people
are aging is changing.
That fifty today is very
different than it was years ago.
Whether you're fifty,
or sixty or seventy,
that it looks very different
than it did for our parents
or our parent's parents and
today with increased longevity
and generally better health and
medical advances, that we're going
to live another twenty
or thirty years longer
than our parents or
grandparents lived.
And as a result of that,
people are living much longer.
The fastest growing age group in
this country is people over the age
of eighty five and second are
people over the age of a hundred.
Ten thousand people a day are
turning the age sixty five
and that's going to happen every
day for the next fourteen years.
We are getting older, but our focus
is really not about how you're going
to age, but how you're
going to live.
So when people say, so why
did you write disrupt aging,
it actually I would say has its
beginnings here at the Library
of Congress because when I turned
fifty my colleague David Alby who is
with me at AARP, him and my
husband cooked up this idea
that they were going to have a
surprise fiftieth birthday party
and it's actually the
introduction to the book.
And then those of you who
have worked with me know
that I don't like secrets.
I like to know exactly what's going
to happen, when it's going to happen
and why it's going to happen
and so my husband decided he
was going to take me to brunch.
We got there.
There were no reservations or
they had lost the reservations.
We had a table back by the kitchen.
And I was getting angrier
and angrier
and then the maître d'came
back and said actually,
I made a mistake you're
in a different room.
And I go over and it was
actually all of my colleagues
from the Library of Congress
celebrating my fiftieth birthday.
But as the story goes, it was
about those birthday cards
of congratulations, you're
fifty, you're over the hill.
You know, you're not getting
older, you're just forgetting
where you put things and all
of those different stereotypes
that we see, so it was that idea
and that concept about where I was
in my own life and how important I
thought it was for us to feel good
about being fifty or sixty or
seventy or eighty or whatever
that number is and this whole
idea about creating the book
around disrupt aging was really to
start a movement in this country
about how do we change the
conversation in this country
about what it means
to be fifty and older.
And how do we focus on positive
aging and positive living,
than looking at it
as something to fear.
I find it fascinating that as we go
around the country talking to folks
that we really see this ah ha
moment of I feel just like that.
I'm so glad you're saying it.
Now I can say it and
sort of repeat it.
But how do we begin
to disrupt aging?
What we're trying to do is to
challenge out dated beliefs
and spark solution so
that more people can live
and chose how they want to age.
As I mentioned earlier,
it's about challenging
out dated beliefs and
sparking new ideas.
That we are creating both
a wide spread awareness
about out dated beliefs
and also trying to engage
and ignite this conversation
and get the private sectors
and the public sectors
involved about how we need
to create new products
and new solutions
that allow people to
live and age better.
So let's begin if I could around
challenging these outdated beliefs.
One of the important
things I think it is,
is really with owning your own age.
I tell everybody I meet
that I'm fifty eight.
I was born in the year that AARP's
founder Doctor Ethel Percy Andrus
started AARP, and also I want to
claim the first permanent woman
to be the CEO in our fifty
eight year here history
and very proud of that.
But it is about this whole
idea that you see in television
and ad magazine commercials
that fifty is the new thirty.
I say fifty is not the new thirty
and sixty is not the new forty,
fifty is the new fifty
and it looks good.
And it's ok to own your age and
feel good about where you are
and what it is you want to
do in your fifty plus life.
If you go to the google search
bar and you type in a word,
I lied about my, the first
thing that pops up is age.
Why do you this?
How many of you have
lied about your age?
You don't have to answer that.
You know, but it's this whole idea
that society thinks
that younger is better.
And so for me, in owning your age
and feeling about where you are
that it's a bout thinking
through and being comfortable
with the experiences that
life has brought you.
And that for me, I know that
I am a more purposeful person
because of the experiences, the
wisdom these years have brought me.
And that we're not getting younger
every day, we're aging every day
from the day we were born and
that we need to own that reality
and feel good about it and
not let us that hold us back
as we're thinking about
what it is we want to do
in these extra years
that are coming to us.
The second part of this is
about fighting ageism, not age.
And there is a big distinction.
Our ability to live longer and
healthier, more productive lives is,
is really one of man-kinds
greatest accomplishments.
Yet we don't often see it that way
and certainly society
doesn't see it that way.
And these negative stereotypes of
aging are so ingrained in our psyche
that they are difficult to overcome
and we don't even try at times
and so this idea of
how do we fight ageism.
How do we call it out
not in a hateful way,
but in a very direct way when you
do it yourself or when you see one
of your colleagues or family
members making fun of someone
because of their age
or making age an excuse
for why you can't do something?
And so that's a huge part of
how we begin to fight ageism
in our own personal lives.
I want to show you a quick video
that and the people you're going
to see in the video didn't
know that they were in this
as part of an AARP infomercial.
They thought they were coming
to apply for an acting job.
And so we launched this
about ten days ago;
so for fourteen million
people have viewed it.
>> Hey how's it going?
You can stand right
there, that's your mark.
How you doing?
>> I'm great, how are you?
>> Great.
>> Awesome.
>> Tell us your first
name and your age.
>> My real age?
>> My name is Palo.
I'm twenty five years old.
>> My name is Danielle
and I'm nineteen.
>> Twenty four.
>> Thirty five.
>> Thirty one.
>> Thirty three.
>> I'm twenty six years old.
>> What age do you
consider to be old?
>> Late forties.
>> Maybe fifty.
>> Um.
>> I feel like thirty's the new
twenty so it's like forty is old.
>> I'd probably say fifties.
>> I'd like you to show me how an
old person would cross the street.
[ Music ]
>> I'm imaging having
some kind of a cane.
[ Music ]
>> How would an old
person do a push up?
[ Music ]
>> Probably couldn't get back up.
>> Show me how an old person
would send a text message.
[ Music ]
>> Do a jumping jack.
>> I'm like envisioning grandma
and grandpa, you're not old, but.
[ Music ]
>> Ok. Hang on there's
someone I want you to meet.
[ Music ]
>> Hello I'm Burt.
I'm sixty six.
>> I'm Bob, I'm sixty five.
>> Hi I'm Daphne and
I'm sixty eight.
>> I'm Neo, fifty nine.
>> I'm Dee and I'm fifty five.
>> George Fassbinder, seventy five.
>> My names Parvatee,
[Assumed Spelling] I'm seventy.
>> Nice to meet you.
>> We're going to give
you about two minutes
to teach each other something
that you are good at.
>> Ok. I can teach
you a jump that I do.
>> Ok, please.
>> Both of your legs go up and
your arms, your right arm goes up
and your left arm goes
like to the side, ready?
>> Ok.
>> One, two, three.
>> One, two, three, lift, one, two,
three and bring it to your heart
and bring it to you
heart and head and yeah.
>> You want to try to get
your balance and rise up
and now bring your
legs and your feet up.
>> Ok.
>> It's hard right?
>> Yeah.
>> One, two, three [Punching Sound].
>> So when you switch you're
just pretty much jumping.
So it's kind of like this.
You can go here, you
can balance with it.
>> Over, now forward, over, yeah.
>> One, two, three, five,
six, seven, so when you come
out of the turn, either way,
you go back to that basic,
you're going to go back
on your right foot, ok?
>> Start like this
and give me a hook.
Hook, jab, cross, hook and then
move, go like this, alright?
>> The nay nay.
>> The nay nay, ok.
>> You're going to whip it.
>> Whip it, ok.
>> The other side, drive that bus.
>> Alright.
>> Now just wave to the people.
>> Ok, I like that,
wave to the people, ok.
>> Now what age might
you consider to be old?
>> Probably eighty or ninety.
He could just do everything
I told him to do.
>> An age I'd consider to
be now might be a hundred.
[Laughter]
>> Do you remember what you said?
>> Yeah. Yeah I said in the
fifties I thought that would be.
When I thought about it.
>> Wait a minute [Inaudible]
>> It really changed my
thinking of what old is.
>> You've taught me something today.
Clearly there's no way
she's old, you know.
>> Now I know from today,
hey, I don't look at age.
>> At my age I feel
capable of doing anything
because I don't think I'm limited.
I think I can do.
>> At my age I feel like I
did when I was in my twenties.
>> In my age I feel like
I'm just getting started.
>> That's just when you put
together everything you've learned.
>> There's so many things
that I still want to do.
There's so many things
that I can do.
As long as I'm growing and
learning, then age doesn't matter.
>> When people start stopping,
that's when they start getting old.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Ok.
>> Thanks Daphne.
>> It was great meeting you.
>> How long have you
been doing this?
Is this a new skill?
>> Forty years.
>> Wow.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Jo Ann Jenkins: What I think is
so fascinating about this video is
that one interaction actually
changes perception of aging
to these young people and
also think for the perception
of the older people
about millennials,
and I think that's what we're
trying to do with disrupt aging
to get people to not judge
someone based on how old they are,
but what they can do and what
they can bring to the table.
If you think about it this way,
today it is socially unacceptable
to ignore, to ridicule, or
stereotype someone based
on their gender, their race,
or their sexual orientation.
Well I said right before
this presidential campaign
that was not acceptable.
So why is it that we still allow
people to make fun and tell jokes
about someone based on their age?
Its part of that cultural
norm that we need to dispel
so that people are judged
based on who they are
and not how old they are.
And as I said, that
particularly video has been viewed
over almost fourteen million times
on Facebook in the last ten days;
so a very powerful exercise.
Disrupt aging also focuses
around new solutions.
So that we as, as we age, are not
having to adapt to what society
or people from the private
sectors, products and services,
that weren't having to adapt to
what they put in the market instead
of them developing products
and services that we need to,
in the market in order to age well.
I focus this around health security,
around financial resilience,
around personal fulfillment or my
short hand health, wealth and self.
How do we start talk about
and getting the private sector
and communities and
you as individuals
to focus on those three areas?
That whole idea requires changing
the way we talk about aging
from something to fear, to
something to look forward to.
In the areas of health, health
area, how do we start thinking
about health and what we're eating
and how we exercise at an early age,
so that as we get to
these additional twenty,
thirty years that we might live
beyond our traditional retirement
age, how do we, how do we start
focusing on those areas early
in life so that our time of
decline is drastically condensed?
In the area of the wealth, how do we
get people to start saving earlier?
And saving longer so that
they don't outlive their money
and that they're not solely
dependent on social security
and then in the area of self, how
do we find that personal fulfillment
in our own lives that allow us to be
able to do the things that we want
to do and think about
what it is we want to do.
I love to use the Maya Angelo
quote and she says that a fifty,
we finally come the person
we always wanted to be.
And how we start in
our fifty plus years,
figuring out who is the
person that we want to be
and how do we go about
living our lives?
I certainly like to focus this
around what I call the three P's,
the personal, private
and public that we need
to take a personal responsibility
on how we go about doing this.
That there is a public
role in our communities
around how we address these
issues and that there's a role
for the private sector at all
levels to start thinking about
and creating new solution for
people who are fifty and over
to allow them to live better.
I often talk about the
example about the car.
That why don't we have a seat that
swivels out that makes it easier
for us to get into the car or makes
it easier for that mother trying
to put that car seat in
to be able to do that.
Many of the solutions that we're
talking about, not only is good
for the old, but also
good for the young
and how do we stop this
pitting against generations,
but really getting us to think
about solutions that are ageless
that allow all of us to live better.
I wanted to just focus
if I could from these,
these state of how we're moving
from to an area as we said,
let's go back to the first
one Camilie on health.
How do we move from physical
and mental diminishment
to physical and mental fitness?
How do we move from being dependent
patients of the health care system
to empower users of our health
information and how we go about
and have conversations with
our doctors and hospitals
and health care providers?
How do we move from that uncertain
access to care to dependable access
to care that we are the ones in the
driver's seat to be able to do this?
And then in the financial areas,
older people viewing older people
as economic burdens to older
people as economic contributors;
people fifty plus contribute
seven point one trillion dollars
at economic activity to our country.
And I always like to say, but
where else but Washington would
that be a problem rather
than a solution
as we're dealing our
friends across the street.
That we move from this
depletion of finances over time
to resources you don't out live
and start thinking about saving
for the life I want to live
rather than saving for retirement.
And do we start thinking
about that at a younger age
so that you are making it
a part of your daily life?
How do we move from an
undervalued fifty plus workforce
to a higher competitive
fifty plus workforce?
Particularly those folks at the
Library, the Library of Congress
and libraries all around the world,
if it were not for our volunteers,
most of whom are fifty and
older, libraries couldn't exist.
They couldn't afford to hire
the workforce that is needed
to do the work that librarians
do all across this country
and how do we use this
fifty plus work force
to help us start solving some of the
issues that are facing our country.
And then in the area of personal
fulfillment, how do we start to move
from aging as only about
decline to aging is about growth?
From the fact aging presents
only challenges that it's an area
of opportunity for the fifty
plus, but also for the community?
And that we start viewing
older people not as burdens,
but as contributors to society as
they continue to live some twenty,
thirty past what is
traditional retirement.
>> And so what I'd
like to do is talk
about what I call the
aging four freedoms.
That a new vision for living and
aging in America and inspire us
to start disrupt aging
in making that a reality.
On January six in nineteen
forty one,
President Franklin Delano
Roosevelt stood before joint session
of Congress to deliver his annual
state of the union address and in
that speech he spoke about four
freedoms that still ranked true
to this day about the basic
values that decline American life
and examples of American
exceptionalism.
He spoke about the freedom of
speech, freedom of worship,
freedom from want and
freedom from fear.
And so much like President
Roosevelt,
we've identified what I
call aging's four freedoms.
The first one is the,
the freedom is chose.
The freedom to choose how you want
to live and age and when it comes
to aging, there is
no one size fits all.
If you want to follow that
traditional path to retirement,
you should be able to do that.
If you want and act and engage life
and you want to continue working,
you should be able
to do that as well.
If you want to retire and live
in a retirement community or live
in an institutional setting,
you should have the opportunity
to do make those decisions and all
of those options should
be available to you.
It's all about having, you having
the options to decide how you want
to live out the rest of your life.
The second freedom, the freedom
to earn, a key part of retirement,
the retirement model that most of us
grew up, was the freedom from work.
That's what retirement
was all about.
That I was going to go
home and not do anything,
but play golf and go on vacation.
But today, a key part of this
extended age is the freedom to work.
Many of us want or need to
continue working in order
to subsidize our financial security
or the fact that we have a lot more
to give back and I think
that's where I found myself
when I left the Library of Congress
to think that I had the opportunity
to retire or go home or, but I
felt like I had a lot more to give
and so I made that choice to make
that transition over to AARP.
But this second freedom is
about giving you the opportunity
and not letting society decide at
a certain age you're no longer able
to work to be able to do that.
And the third freedom, freedom to
learn; and this certainly applies
to the work that you guys do
here at the Library of Congress
which is the need to keep
learning and staying engaged
and being involved in a productive
during this extended little age
that gives you the opportunity to be
engaged to avoid social isolation,
to be able to have those
learning experiences.
You know I often talk about
the idea that we are going
to continue learning throughout our
life time and how important it is
for us to stay engaged in
a learning environment.
To keep up with the
use of technology,
to be to stay engaged
rather in libraries
or in traditional education
settings.
But that we should
have the opportunity
to continue to learn as we age.
And then the fourth freedom,
the freedom to pursue happiness,
that this is about discovering and
fulfilling your purpose in life
and really becoming the person
that you've always wanted to be.
This extra twenty or thirty
years gives us an extraordinary
opportunity to become the people
that we've always wanted to be;
that we're no longer
burdened by the day
to day stresses that
consume our lives.
Most of our kids are
off to college or work;
hopefully they're not coming
back in, but to visit,
but it gives us an extraordinary
opportunity to do what it is we want
to do as adults and be able to focus
on ourselves and on our communities
and live our life with
meaning and purpose.
So in winning these four freedoms
it gives each of us an opportunity
to really become the
person that we wanted to be,
but I wanted to give
you this challenge.
In conversations with your family
and friends, and I've had some
of those conversation with you
as I've come back here today,
and in your work not only in
the library, but in your family
and communities, how will you start
to challenge these outdated
beliefs about aging.
In your own life and in your work
what solutions will you spark
in everything you do, think
about the new possibilities
that you can create for
yourself and for those around you
and in your communities so
that we begin this conversation
about disrupt aging and not
judging people by how old they old,
but giving the opportunity to see
the value that you bring back.
So we're excited about the book.
I'm delighted to be here
at back at the Library.
I told David when we
left the office;
let's go home, back
over the Library.
And everybody at AARP went ahhhh.
But it's an exciting time for
all of us as we think about aging
and thinking about
the possibilities.
I know that one of the unique things
about the work that we do at AARP
and the Library of
Congress is that both
of us have very similar
kinds of work places.
People work at AARP and
at the Library of Congress
because they believe
and love the mission.
It is also one of the places
that I know that when I was here
at the Library, the majority of the
employees were over the age of fifty
and that if you go down and
you talk to Jim Hudson or one
of those other curators,
they're not thinking
about leaving this institution
because they have so
much to give back.
And I think that's what
disrupt aging is all about.
How do we create opportunities and
value what people have to give?
So thank you all for
having me here today.
We'll be, I think available
to sign books
in the Congressional Reading Room.
Am I saying too much?
Are you going to do that?
So thank you all very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Newlen: Jo
Ann thank you so much.
I learned a lot.
I loved that video.
I was feeling a little
verklempt at the end of it.
It was so, so well done.
Jo Ann is absolutely right,
we're going to have a reception
in the back of the room and
then she will be signing books
in our Congressional
Reading Room next door.
So Jo Ann thank you so much.
It was so nice to meet your
colleagues from AARP today
and thank you all for coming.